the hot issue now is the vaccine
passport
this is the big issue that everybody's
talking about uh naomi wolf
was on tucker carlson and she was
talking about now she's a
feminist writer naomi wolfe right yes
yes she is
um i always mix her up with the other
naomi naomi climb but it's naomi wolfe
was on tucker carlson talking about this
and saying this is much
more than just a vaccine passport
and i wanted you to talk about that
because i know that you've looked into
this
and it's a contentious issue there are
some people that dismiss
any concerns about it and go anybody
that has any questions about a vaccine
passport is a lunatic
and shouldn't be listened to and then
there are people
uh uh where where i am where i go i
don't really know what a vaccine
passport is
i don't know that i trust people to tell
me what it is
in your estimation what is a vaccine
passport and how
could it be used okay so what we need to
understand about the vaccine passports
they're promoting now is that they were
never
they're not intended to stop with being
vaccine passports it's something that's
going to be much more expansive and
extensive
if it gets its foot in the door so i'm
back in january i wrote about something
called the vaccine credential initiative
a public private partnership with
microsoft oracle force of the mitre
corporation a us government contractor
all coming together to create the
framework for vaccine passports of
course a couple months before
there's this big public uh push but they
called them smart health cards
and called them vaccine wallets um and
this is basically the
the framework that a lot of these
passports at some point will be
um running on some of the ones in use
are already uh
running on this this protocol it's
interesting they call it a wallet
because the developer of this uh this
framework at microsoft talks about how
you may need to show your vaccine
passport to be able to rent a car
someday in the future and of course them
using the term wallet
implies that this is going to move into
economic activity at some point
and if you look at for example bill
gates's gabi the vaccine alliance
they've already partnered with
mastercard
to combine mastercard's digital payment
service with
gabby's digital vaccine card and they're
currently piling that in africa
uh the gabby mastercard thing in
combination with a company called uh
trust stamp which is biometric identity
so basically what these vaccine
passports are intended to be
is a digitized vaccine record
uh plus a digital wallet and then a
biometric id
all in one yeah why is that why is
mastercard involved i mean call me
ignorant here
and many have but why is mastercard
involved with a vaccine passport what
why would you need any type of financial
like why would they need any of your
financial information that confuses me
it's a partnership to have everything
moved
to these mobile based uh systems i guess
where it's a it's a biometric id that
gives you access to your money
through your by providing your
biometrics your face your fingerprint or
whatever and then
also has a vaccine your vaccine registry
but really it's not intended to stop at
vaccine registry it's intended to be
your electronic health records and
basically have it all
uh be there tied up together and if you
actually go and look at the vaccine
credential initiative and the stuff they
talk about and their partners talk about
i mean it's really obvious that this has
been the plan
um from the beginning and you know this
gabby mastercard partnership is just
one but it's worth pointing out that a
lot of these same actors including
mastercard are part of something called
the
council for inclusive capitalism uh
which is
supposedly headed by the pope but has a
mastercard and visa and some of the
biggest companies in the world
wait a minute there's a council for
inclusive
activism uh capitalism capitalism headed
by the
wait a minute headed by the pope yes uh
officially and it's about redesigning
a new system a new economic system
for everyone in the world under the
moral guidance of the pope
and so you have the ceos of all these
really it's really insane
so um
when did that get going well it gets
better
it really does now some of the people on
there are lynn forester de ross child
the jeffrey epstein bill clinton powell
is on their reimagining capitalism for
everyone
um and then you have the water family
from estee lauder like ron water
yeah he's one of these mega group
billionaire guys that i wrote about in
the epstein series and stuff so like
there are so it's you know it's funny
it's reimagining capitalism but it's
people that capitalisms worked very well
for
yeah yeah like why would they want to
really reimagine
capitalism they're doing quite well well
this is about the stakeholder capitalism
idea that has come in that has come out
from the world economic forum and that
this
pope-led council is is promoting and
basically what they want is uh you know
basically global public-private
partnership to be the
model of governance globally um and of
course public private partnership
basically means
you know the public and private fuse
together uh there's another
word for that that has been used
historically but this is what they're
going around promoting
and saying that it will uh but under the
guise of it being called stakeholder
capital let's see
so now what's that what's the pro word
that's been used historically fascism
yeah well yeah um and you basically have
one
entity that is the power that you cannot
challenge and has a monopoly on force
and
right and the production of goods and
everything else i mean
chris hedges calls it the corporate
state and he said it's the most powerful
force in the world is the corporate
state
it's mega corporations fused with the
national security state
good luck like good luck you know
penetrating that
i just love this idea of a council led
by the pope
uh to reimagine capitalism with all
these billionaires on it